I got room for one mo
thanks for being here both of you so
Jennifer you've had six by my count
nominations from the Spirit Awards over
your career amongst countless other
nominations but this is the first
Academy Award nomination what does that
mean to you it's a pretty big deal I
mean it doesn't get much bigger than
that you know so it also I loved making
this movie so very very much and it in a
way it keeps the movie alive for me
because when a movie comes out there's
always if you love it it almost feels
like an end and there's something
bittersweet about it you get to share it
with the world and your friends and your
family but it's kind of over for you and
the crew you know but this keeps it
alive a little longer so it's just it's
meaningful in so many ways and that's
that's two of them Bob you've worked
with Quentin several times for the last
20 years I believe over 15 years did you
always know that you'd be a good fit
with him before you started working with
him when you saw his previous films I
didn't think I'd be a good fit even when
I was with him Quinton and bit by bit
over Kill Bill and into inglorious we
became closer and closer and so now I do
feel I said well what about you Jennifer
was he someone you had always had your
eye on wanting to work with oh yes I
mean since I saw Reservoir Dogs I've
been wanting to work with him so that's
that's quite a while now a very long
time yeah what would you each say is
unique about working with him and you've
worked extensively also Bob with Oliver
Stone and Martin Scorsese what's
specific and special about working with
Quinton as far as your job is concerned
his love of the word he honors the word
deeply which makes for beautiful
performances is work with actors is
phenomenal and a degree of focus he has
upon both that word and the acting is
something he also puts into the way he
moves a camera how about yourself he's
unlike any director I've ever worked
with his and through
Azzam his like sheer joy he loves
filmmaking so much and he appreciates
what everyone he he really demands the
best and the most you have to give and
and he gets it and he appreciates
everything that everyone brings and he
just makes it fun you just you want to
be on the set how do each of you how did
each of you learn about all of the
insane stuff that happens in this movie
was did he sit in a general meeting and
tell you about oh so this is what I'm
thinking it's gonna be in 70 millimeter
and you're gonna get vomited on and this
is what's gonna happen or did you sit in
a room and read it and learn that for
the first time there well a lot of it's
in the script
but in the original script my brother's
head did not get blown off so that I
kind of found out maybe the day before
it happened that was kind of a big big
one what's the one thing when you read
the script for the first time that you
thought I can't believe that I'm gonna
do this was it blowing snot out your
nose now that I just did cuz I haven't a
half snot in my nose and I thought I
would just you know he wanted everything
from Daisy just to come from inside so
if you know I felt that I did it
ya know what was the craziest thing I
mean just the idea of being invited to
being the only woman in this epic
Western was kind of thrilling and
extraordinary for me and then to be so
embraced by the group and she's just
didn't I mean it's an incredible
incredible role what did you guys want
to do with the look of the film that
maybe you hadn't done in previous
collaborations oh well principally it's
II do the capability and the opportunity
to shoot with 65 millimeter was rather
unique finding these old lenses was
remarkable opportunity and to work in
what I thought was a heightened reality
with the use of color and
beauty of the bronze can you in layman's
terms explain what shooting on the
format that you did adds two things I
mean and then when I heard it was in
that format I thought it was just going
to be all kind of huge landscapes but so
much of it is more intimate close-ups
what did that all add to the equation
well I don't think formats vital to
where there was sixteen thirty five or
seventy millimeter as much as what
happened with the 70 millimeter is it
brought the intimacy of the phases much
more alive and I think you can read a
performance like Jennifer's remarkable
as well as everyone it's to see their
eyes is with that clarity and also all
the mannerisms on such a large screen
such as this or even larger as a
Ziegfeld or wherever it's quite
astounding yeah so the beauty of the
format is literally that the scale of
the negative so many times you hear
actors say like with HD like oh my god I
can't believe I'm gonna be shot in HD
was there any part of you that went oh
god what does this mean it's gonna be in
seventy millimeter or was that not
somebody went through your mind well not
when you have Bob shooting you you feel
like you're in very good hands I mean I
feel like there's scenes where I mean
Quentin I remember one day early on I
said to Heba the makeup artist there's
only one kind of mascara I can use
because my eyes that bleed mascara
always please and she said oh no you're
not wearing mascara in this movie and
that was the the first time I realized
oh okay all right I'm game and then you
know more and more blood and more blood
and more blood and vomit and blood and
then I watched it daily and I was seeing
myself covered in blood but with Bob's
lighting was like gee I look so pretty
so I was never afraid because bob was
shooting me and Quentin was directing me
and so it was like a free fall that just
felt so safe and so good how often do
they have to reapply I mean did did it
get all cakey and then he had to kind of
take it it's sticky as [ __ ] so it was
like always but I was just so happy so I
didn't mind you know I was so thrilled
to be a part of this movie so I never my
did any of it but yeah it's really
really you can't move your fingers they
have to spray you down with water and
then they have to put more blood on top
of the water and you know from each of
your perspectives what would you each
say was the best and the worst part
about shooting in the snow the cold was
the best part was one of the worst part
and the snow is one of the most
beautiful parts it was a good and about
good trade-off what about for you the
the hardest part I would say was when we
were outside trying to determine the
wiser choice to stay in the carriage or
to stay in the snow or to walk the two
football fields to the warming tent so I
would often choose to conserve my energy
and stay in the snow stay in the
carriage and I I I wouldn't recommend
that if you're ever faced with that
choice like go go to the Warmington and
then I've read an interview with you Bob
where you said that I guess a lot of
this was filmed in a studio here in
California that was incredibly cold was
that because there just wasn't the
capability of making it warmer or was
that because Quentin wanted it to be
really cold Quinton walnut very cold he
had numerous refrigerator trucks lining
the studio stage which is red studio it
was initially intended that we would
shoot only a third of the film on
location or maybe even less
and as we shot there and the weather
didn't come in we ended up shooting over
half or approximately half of the film
on on a location that did it wasn't
completely practical so no walls move or
anything for other shots and some of
these shots as you can tell needed to
move walls and then we moved to the
stage in Quinton one breath so it had to
be at a certain level which was which
made it unbearable everybody would
attempt to sabotage the refrigeration
system well it occurred to me that you
all could have said you know Quentin
were professional actors we can act like
we're cold you know this wouldn't be
that hard to do but they act breath
right you can't act
they can't put that in in
post-production it looks like crap it
really does I mean you can always you
know when you're watching movie and they
CGI the breath you're always distracted
by it you see you're like something's
off in the scene it just pulls you out
of the movie so and Quentin just hates
anything that's not real
and Quentin tried to avoid all visual
effects wherever possible and movie his
attempt is to do it all in camera so
even the finish of the film it's done a
digital intermediate as you can see it's
just straight it's not scanning and
putting it onto film it's a chemical
release so what you shoot on the set is
what you are watching we have no
capability repairing what we did what I
did
there's some great added sound though I
mean when you take the elbow in the face
there's a that sound effect is so great
well what was your reaction to I mean it
must be one thing to shoot that but then
to see it in a huge screen and to see
yourself being treated so violently with
that heightened sound it must be a very
strange sensation
I mean honestly seeing myself on the
poster is a strange sensation yeah I
what's great is that all the hits really
work and I never got hurt I mean Kurt
never missed and that's that's saying a
lot cuz he hits me an awful lot it
speaking of Kurt when I interview the
two of you together I have just remarks
upon the fact that you've chained
together through the whole movie and
what you must learn about someone when
you're chained to someone for that long
a period of time but now what I want to
know is at what kind of intervals were
you able to unchain yourself just to
have some away time you know we could
sometimes I mean whenever we finished a
scene we would get you know unlocked and
yeah when we weren't shooting we weren't
locked when we were shooting a scene we
usually stayed cuffed is there a
particular shot or scene that you would
tell people who are watching this
because this is being filmed that took
that you really love a shot that you
think is particularly cool or gorgeous
no I don't have
any particular shot in mind I did read
something that you think the color red
has a specific pop particularly the red
in her face very well it she does look
beautiful and you've seen this now
several times where you think sometimes
it's a beautiful beautiful projection
and other times it's not as great what
accounts for whether it really lives up
to its full potential the men in the
booth nice I'm sure you all have
questions for these two but what can I
in what can I question is how many weeks
the shoot took months but I'm not but
some of that might have been rehearsal
we started in November rehearsing and
then we finished late May I think well
what is it how many months is that I
don't know I think five or six okay hi
the question is how's Jennifer having
Jennifer get cast and and what the
preparation was I was honest
I guess it's um somewhat short list of
actresses that Quentin was interested in
he had most of the roles he knew he
wanted to cast but Daisy he wasn't sure
and I got an email from my agent saying
that I should pick up the script and I
was going to be reading at Quentin's
house so I did and there was I had the
whole script for two days before my
audition but I was missing the last
chapter and so Daisy doesn't talk a lot
in the movie and so I read it several
times and then I went to Quentin's house
and we talked for a long time about
Daisy and he wanted to know my thoughts
about her and then he came in with a
last chapter and he said okay why don't
you read this I'll give you some time
and then we'll read from that and then I
started reading it and Daisy suddenly
speaks quite a lot and so that was a
little daunting and I you know I was a
little scared but I just I once had an
acting teacher who said think of an
audition as a time you get to own that
part and it may be only be for that ten
minutes but for that ten minutes it's
yours
and I also love Quentin's movies so much
and all I had to lose was the part you
know all I had to I could if I held back
it would be over and I might as well
have a great time but what he did is he
came in and he sat next to me and opened
his script and we just read together
which most directors don't read with you
they watch you but he actually reads
with you and that's a good indicator of
just what he's like as a person and as a
director you really felt like he was
with you and you were acting together
and it was play and it was fun and you
suddenly felt in a way fearless he just
brings that out and everybody because he
you feel like his it sounds corny but
you feel his love and his enthusiasm for
what you do did you feel good about it
when you walked out the room know what
when I walked out I my mom made me
promise that I would call her which I
did and she said how did it go and I
said I actually have no idea but I had
the time of my life
and really if it had stopped there I
would have just had such a great day so
the fact that I'm sitting here right now
is really like darling and then how does
he let you know is it a phone call or
does it through your representatives um
I got a call that he want to have dinner
to discuss the role and we did that and
then he told me basically he had like a
few more people that he had to read and
he had to read them but that he was
feeling very good about me in this part
whoa and then it was like another two
weeks before I found out and has it ever
happened where you've heard that from a
filmmaker and then you ended up not
getting it where you were kind of led on
to believe that you would but you didn't
or did you know at that point this is a
done deal for me I didn't know no
because someone can always come in and
blow you out of the water you know so I
didn't know but I I felt optimistic but
also very what's that word where you're
superstitious or trepidatious like I
didn't want to think that I had it
because I didn't thanks for the question
who else the question is about Quentin's
directorial methods if he wants an
adjustment in between takes how does he
go about making that known and how many
takes roughly do you do usually he has
so many different like brilliant
waise I mean there's like the obvious
way of try it like this and Kurt would
say it's gonna seem crazy sometimes but
just do it like don't even think about
it and you know you really do know with
him that you can just trust it and all
you you know I have to do is just you
know give yourself over to it he demands
that you like really know the lines
backwards and forwards and no cell
phones and and then there's other like
really just subtle things like he lets
you kind of find things behaviorally and
he wants that and he wants it to come
from you and he really lets things kind
of play out I'd say we do wet it on
average like four takes maybe four not
very many any final questions high
question is whether she liked Daisy as a
character yeah I loved her didn't you
all love her she's an angel
did you notice the angel wings when she
was hanging there you go last question
oh my gosh yes question is about the
differences between working and digital
and in film there's a substantial amount
of difference the primary difference is
of course the speed of which digital is
working nowadays so your lighting
package can drop I still think there are
very strong similarities in the need of
both to for film to come out well and
that's composition lighting and etc I
think that they don't alter that much
substantially once your whether it's
film or whether it's digital I you just
have to get your hands on the digital so
that you can break it down a bit so it's
not quite so sports oriented in some
cases we've time for a little more right
here question is whether there were
outright allusions to the Exorcist we
didn't actually talk about the Exorcist
but there is one moment where I
completely stole from that movie because
I it actually is one of my favorite
movies and it's after Reagan kills the
priest
just because that feeling of having so
much power but also being completely
lost that Linda Blair was so she was so
damn good in that but you really felt
that all that power and then just the
mania of having got what you finally
wanted but now what do you do you know
and just so yeah I totally ripped that
off and then Quentin of course it was
like I saw what you did he liked it but
he knew he knew exactly well I think I
speak on behalf of everyone I say thank
you for making us laugh and thank you
for grossing us out with this movie
congratulations on the Oscar nominations
Robert Richardson and Jennifer Jason
Leigh have a great night
now we're talking